Cristi, regarde-moi, je veux que tu te souviennes de
quelque chose parce que souvent les gens
obtiennent de belles choses et je commence à penser
différemment, nous sommes arrivés ici grâce à un travail acharné, à la
patience et à l'humilité, alors je veux te dire de
ne jamais penser que le monde
te doit  n'importe quoi parce que ce n'est pas le
monde ne te doit rien J'ai été
major de promotion au lycée Je suis entré dans
une université chic Je suis resté ici parce que mes
parents divorcent
Wow tu sais ce que tu devrais te faire comme
une fuite de gaz que nous faisons  Je ne te vois pas, nous ne le
passons pas avec toi en train de nous tuer en silence
peut-être que ton rêve à travers l'espoir pour l'
instant c'est la bonne façon de le dire
belle se marier quand même docteur un
avocat ou un homme gentil Stan ça je ne
sais même pas quoi dire  appelez ce gars parlez-vous
sérieusement de ça en ce moment
je crois que l'ordinaire rencontre l'
extraordinaire chaque jour j'ai de
vraies ambitions et de vraies idées pour faire une
invention c'est un choix très sérieux
ne jamais diriger une entreprise de toute sa vie
ouais c'est de ma faute  Je lui ai donné la
confiance de penser qu'elle était plus qu'une
simple femme au foyer au chômage
Je ne veux pas finir comme ma famille
Je dois faire les choses moi-même une fois pour
toutes d'accord Godspeed bonne chance on y va alors
que tu grandis et tu viens  dans le
monde qui a toutes sortes de choses dedans l'
argent le
crime la trahison semble nous ébranler
tu peux payer plus je ne peux pas je ne sais pas
tu réalises que la seule chose que
tu vas avoir est ce que tu fais de
toi  dans une pièce et il y a une arme sur la
table je veux que ma vie soit la seule
autre personne dans la pièce est un adversaire
dans la conversation un seul d'entre vous peut l'
emporter prenez-
vous l'arme Troie je prends l'arme
ne doit jamais parler  en mon nom à propos de mes
affaires encore j'aime quelqu'un pour nous
certains d'ailleurs je t'aime